[Music]
however they want to feel about you but
you shouldn't be talking to them if
you're genuinely serious about the
person you're dating all right it's
official it's on the Whiteboard yes
so for the girls 100 cheating if you're
going places raise your hand cheating
raise your hand oh
absolutely all right
even saying I've got a man is cheating
all right I wouldn't say this for boys
is cheating I would not say that at all
because faithful girls don't reply so
even if you even to reply I've got a man
that's cheating because if he was
faithful you've even got a reply you
just air it just air it you keep it in
your request to reply or you block or
basically yeah but paper girls don't
reply yeah okay okay
so
all right posting a third strap so
you got a girl she posted thirst trap
why ass pick
is that cheating oh wait no we're doing
the boys first I'm sorry I'm sorry you
guys got a man he posts uh a shirtless
pic it's not the same men and women not
sexualize the same way yeah
just as long as I don't see the v in the
picture then no the V is in it
no no but if your man is a muscular man
the V is always going to be there like
even no no what with a towel
to want to share your progress on
Instagram in that respect
well that's what I'm saying he has no
business it's not it's not a business
it's just purely attraction it's just
trappy then yeah to be honest with when
men do that I don't ever rate that
anyway like so okay so raise your hand
if you think it's cheating
um
so red flag but not sure but I think
it's red flag for other reasons not that
you know what I mean can I just say you
might call me post some topless pictures
yeah facts okay yeah that's a bit
um so then for the girls opposite
so ass picture it's like one of the
thong bikinis it's not even just a
bikini it's a thong bikini
any other way about it did yeah
no you shouldn't be doing it
if you were trying to be someone's wife
you're trying to bear this man's surname
I don't think
so we're all we're all together on this
cheating so
oh gosh I'm bad news writing but see I'm
helping save relationships now this is
the everyone can know exactly where the
line is they're gonna screenshot wait
hold on hold on hold on we're cheating
not but red strike so so basically I'll
here you go so don't worry class I'll
explain so
the reason I put a red flag this means
you can get away with it you won't get
dumped but it is a red flag so it'll be
like
um I don't really like that I'll keep an
eye on it but the relationship isn't
over where this cheating means
relationship over dumped
may I ask why is that so different for
boys as it is girls
um for the posting thirst traps
well I mean we we came together as a
group I was just writing out what the
group said I would say it's because like
women are more sexualized than men or
like I wouldn't want like we sexualize
ourselves but like men are more visual
than women are so I would say it's like
a different effect would you not also
say that's part of the point that sex is
part of the the gift that women have to
give to men in the respect that women or
the bearers or sex men can't really have
sex with the women unless
so you get something I get something out
you don't like this there's a there's
this thing that women say I'm giving you
sex no like yeah but I'm giving you
something back so women like sex and men
like sex so let's not act like you're
actually giving me something unless
you're a virgin that's the only time
you're giving me something if not you're
just giving me something you're giving
to someone else he misunderstood my
point you're not going to have sex with
a woman unless she tells you you can
have sex with her right yeah okay so my
point being is that it's a very
sexualized position that women come from
when it comes to relationships that's
why it's it's so much more graphic when
a woman comes forward and is naked on
Instagram
because Lord nobody wants to see men's
dicks that's the truth of the matter
it's not pretty it's not nobody wants to
see it like it's like if you go and set
like what do women always talk about
these dick pics like it's the most I
don't understand why a man will do it
because you just sense that into a woman
and women don't want to see that but a
woman's body actually other women like
women's bodies and they talk about
women's right body no man starts talking
about another man's body and if they do
that but the point is why is that
because we come from a place where sex
is what we have to go on but women
sexualize themselves like I don't look
at like I've said before like men we
value we value youth Purity and um
loyalty right that's one of some of the
things that we value out none of them
was sex but this thing where a girl's
got to be like oh what the sex ain't
right like that's because you think to
yourself you need to come with something
but I've said it before and I'll say it
again when a girl is doing that mad
thing bro you know that mad thing like
you're saying that go go three thousand
but all you can think to yourself is
where did she learn this like you're
enjoying it like but I'm not trying to
laugh off you know I'm saying I would
like to teach my wife that but she's
coming and she's coming all prepared
that's not something men we value but
for one night yeah of course I'm gonna
value that I'm gonna tell my boys about
it but I would never wife that okay so
can I ask in that respect then what in a
relationship does a woman have to offer
you in general what does a woman offer
you in a relationship
sorry how do you mean in that respects
what does a woman actually offer you
what because I I don't see any other
part in this apart from what a woman has
to offer your platform maybe what she
can give to you in terms of her mind but
a big part but yes that's true but I
just said a second ago is gratification
for man isn't it yeah
I'm sure all the men in the screen can
agree that you have a level of
testosterone that when your woman is
next to you naked you're going to get
[Music]
no it's okay I just I don't I would have
something to say if I understood what
you were talking about so I just don't
understand what you're arguing
yeah I think that a lot of what a woman
has to offer Madden is three sex I mean
be bad children if
no but we have sex such a like if you
think about all the time you spend with
your girl or your partner think about
how much time you actually have sex with
them like if that's all you have to
offer it's going to be very boring for
them and that's what we use girls that
you're going to meet for one that stands
for because that's what they're offering
right like you have to offer so much
more than sex and pro and and something
that's been lost along the way I don't
know whether or not you're people's
fathers or mothers haven't told them but
you have to be there's so much other
things that men want other than sex yeah
like I think like I think of my mom like
she created like traditions for her
whole family that we would do and it it
might sound simple but it was like a lot
of work for her to put together these
like family traditions that everyone
would do so like I feel like a wife
creates a home yes more than anything
and like yeah that's like that put it
this way what can you offer more than
what a prostitute can't
put it this way if you only if you only
can bring sex to the table and you think
that's all we care about then you're
going down the wrong road
yeah I believe my point was
misunderstood I'm not saying that all
women have to offer a sex but what I am
saying is is that if a man were to get
married to a woman and she didn't
provide those duties in that respect I
think it would be very appeasing no she
has to provide sex that's what I do yeah
so I think it should work on the same
grounds in a basic relationship where
you're just girlfriend and boyfriend
you're trying to work towards them no
because you shouldn't be giving your
boyfriend the same thing you give to
your husband this is where the problems
happen this is literally where the
problems happen like you give to random
guys why not guys and short-term
relationship boyfriends the same
actually more than what you give to your
husband because you don't give him your
Purity do you and a lot of the times
what tends to happen is when you meet a
girl and they say to you um you know
I've got insecurities or you know what I
just don't trust people this is because
of previous relationships right so when
they say oh you know I've learned things
I've learned sex or whatever that is for
us like we don't value that because
along with that sexual skills that
you've learned you've learned you had a
lot of hurt and a lot of trauma now I'm
dealing with this I'd rather a girl who
hasn't gone in dated all these different
guys because she thought they were
footballers and rappers or whatever and
these aren't the guys that were ever
gonna wire for you then by the time you
actually start coming back to a normal
level and you meet a guy like me I'm
dealing with the reminiscence of this
and this is what happens and as a man in
his 30s
um that wants to get married that comes
from a family that that everyone is
married with with child that is
something I aspire to you and the reason
I haven't got it is because I keep
meeting problematic
um boss [ __ ] who don't wanna who
believe submission is some type of
um negative word but but there's a lot
of power and femininity you guys don't
understand how much in actual fact we go
to work for you everything we do is for
you and you don't even realize it well I
I'm not coming from the prospects that
you know women all only have sex to
offer and coming from the prospects that
if you're in a relationship with someone
you're going to have agreements aren't
you you're going to say okay I've
acquired this are you going to be able
to agree with that and from that you're
going to say like okay well yes or no
that's not going to be what it is for
people isn't it right so all I'm saying
is is that I perfectly understand that
for some people all they have to offer
is certain things right but I personally
think that you know if a person is
asking for something such a sex in that
respect it should be your requirement to
offer and if you're trying to work
towards something higher like in the
future you both have plans to get
married why wouldn't you want to work
towards trying to appease your partner
in that respect
so how did we get from
this back to the board yeah okay so
so all right class we got a little off
topic but we're going back so this was
actually requested to be brought on by
my producer
um I don't know he knows some wild
people I guess because he asked is
sleeping in the same bed as someone
cheating but you're not doing anything
yes yeah yeah I sleep on the floor
listen if Austin and DM even said I've
got a man is cheating what'd you think
yeah well we'll just let's just I just
in case there's any confusion
for both for both yes does a guy get any
props if he sleeps in the same bed as a
girl and doesn't hook up I'm gonna be
real with you yeah like we've slept in
girls beds and we haven't hooked up with
him and I just I don't know but I know
if a girl sleeps on a guy's bed she's
hooking up with him but if a guy sleeps
on the girls bed doesn't mean hooking up
with her wow
because women are the gateway to sex
thank you thank you hold on hold on hold
on
let you sleep in her bed knowing that
you will never cause the only way you
can get that is by her by giving it to
you right trust me on this yeah she will
actually let you sleep in the bed and
make you roast and not give you nothing
yeah and even as a friend a girl will
let you sleep on a bed and you know
she's your friend and you'll never try
because you know she's a friend but if a
girl says does it the opposite way
around just know it's a wrap she goes in
the guy's bedside
I was trying to say like how can you say
that if a girl you just said the same
thing
no because women are different right I'm
being honest with you right you you
could let a man sleep in your bed and
you know you're not going to give him
nothing right honestly unless you're not
that type of woman then if you're that
type of woman that does that then it
throws it out of the window right but
most women can let a man sleep in their
bed they've let their friends before at
Uni or something that you know what I
mean let it crash and it's been okay but
if if it's the opposite way around
I was in a relationship as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible